but dude had all the answers
so i agree with you man kate okay not
the queen spawn not the king's porn
either
the night developing itself first so the
reti opening named after the hungarian
uh grandmaster richard retti it's
actually my favorite move as well
bringing the white knight out and okay
black reacts by just pushing a pawn in
the center compare openings you compare
certain positions but you are always
that one move down and that can be a
crucial difference and okay dude pretty
much plays copycat there pushing upon
himself
okay the bishop does develop black will
do the same
dude maybe just pouring himself some tea
there maybe that's part of his routine
his superstitions
um
yeah um
i i was just gonna ask you david i was
gonna ask you to look ahead a few moves
and do you think that magnus will
challenge the black pawn in the center
immediately with um
like the c2 the sea pawn move it up two
squares or do you think he's just gonna
wait a while and uh
see what happens before he takes that
commitment i was gonna say he would wait
a while i've seen him play many many
online games magnus cast against hikaru
nakamura actually in this exact opening
and he tends to wait until black has
decided whether to occupy the center
with pawns or to bring his night out and
we've seen a couple of moves white's
king castling why did challenge black
central pawn there and black could have
taken a pawn for free but that pawn
would have dropped off later on in the
game so black just keeping everything
solid defending all his pawns okay and
now uh what do you think about this uh
turn of events he's uh
pushed the b pawn forward just to
support the pawns but at the same time
this is allowed black to top him with
the knight into the center yup this is
still well known stuff i've had this
position many times countless times with
white and with black it's in blitz games
and this is my favorite move just
pushing a pawn forward one square
solidifying white center
the one thing magnus doesn't want to do
is actually trade off a set of pawns in
the center that would free up black's
position very simple plans and
just as i was going to ask you to
predict the next move for black we have
it on the board and i know that you're
very fond of this porn move i'm not i'm
never very sure when uh magnus brings
out the noodles because it looks like he
does well and then suddenly blunder on
the board van farist in this position
and okay black brings his other night
out instead and i expect white to just
maintain the status quo just bringing
the queen across one square actually
magnus in a queen end game so just
queens and pawns left on the board he
had a queen and two pawns against a lone
queen and
it's tricky with best play it should be
a draw but the final position was
actually winning for magnus solid yeah
so if we do see a nitrate yeah as we
have
have just done we're expecting black's
bishop to plant itself on this square
and that's because in these types of
pawn structures the two most important
pieces are actually these fiancee
bishops plant the bishop into the center
is now if it doesn't happen then white
is now given an opportunity to start
chasing away the light square bishop
with the knight and actually it has
happened you have predicted it the black
bishop trying to neutralize white piece
here and uh
okay white has a lot of choice one of
the moves i remember analyzing and
thinking was the critical test of black
setup is this one pawn takes pawn and
normally you don't want to trade these
set of pawns uh because here is just
completely symmetrical with the pawn
structure pretty much no chance of
passports but you have created a square
for your queen to use because uh the
black pawns have no control magnus does
it and you are also starting to finally
create some threats with white and this
is actually very annoying to deal with
okay we do have a move the queen has
developed to
the sea line and uh i'm fully expecting
a rook to actually appear on that line
quite quickly so black's queen defending
the pawn next to it and also trying to
counter-attack against white's bishop
but that bishop has been protected now
by white's rook white's rook on an open
line and
jan christophe duda he's offered that
queen trade so we're now heading towards
an end game all the pieces are getting
traded but there is an imbalance finally
because if you look at this sea lion
white's rook nicely placed and black has
a backward pawn on that line like a
microchip instead exactly of course
ah
and okay just the pawn pose there from
duda he's actually allowing a trade of
bishops on white terms which is slightly
surprising if he doesn't want to trade
these bishops however um in the current
position maybe he could kick black's
bishop away he could push a pawn no he
does trade and okay now he lifts up his
rook instead the plan is to bring the
other rook across move the bishop away
and use the rooks on this line against
the black pawn can we kind of do an
operation activate trade off the pawns
okay it's on the board wow okay nice you
predicted it and maybe yeah
maybe you can uh bring the knight now
into the center of the board maybe this
is one strategy david
wow i was surprised i thought this would
never happen in a million years but it's
actually on the board and now a big
moment for duda he needs to activate
this knight i feel
uh okay no he pushes a pawn first but
this allows white bishop to drop back
and how are you defending this pawn
totally
so okay he has retreated the bishop just
as you indicated okay and dude just
pushing his pawns forward one square oh
okay he has a different plan in mind it
didn't even occur to me maybe we can
keep an eye on the players while we show
this but that's surprising to me is
magnus frowning now
i would be frowning because after white
has just won a pawn for free black's
bishop has stepped back attacking this
pawn yes but you can defend it simply no
yeah um i mean for example you can just
bring your rook across to defend this
pawn you can even bring your knight
across maybe to defend it
it looks like a clear pawn an extra pawn
advantage now for magnus carson he's
used the knight to defend the pawn here
in the first round forusia it's not the
end of the game yes it's a pawn up but
at the moment the black rooks are doing
a good job of stopping white's extra
pawn on the b line marching forward i'm
looking at the pieces i think it's hard
to improve the white knight and white
bishop they're pretty much stuck where
they are but this one is a nice move
that's a nice move brook's behind the
pawns
okay and now
now the night centralizes itself that is
a beautiful night there's no denying it
but uh
is that enough that black has one good
piece
yeah it shouldn't be enough probably and
magnus he's getting greedy now he's
going after black's pawn there and did
something there
he did it
cool
yeah i uh admire his patience yeah and
that's good strategy long term as well
because now blacks pawns that especially
that black pawn that has just pushed
it's locked down white structure on the
right side so white is never going to
get any activity on that side of the
board then you're just saying hey i have
a
whoa this has done it
the top players in the world they tend
to take their opportunity to push if
they can especially with pawns in
engames and white has pushed this pawn
forward okay that's a nice move the
reason i was reluctant is because i
thought you could happen at any time and
now it's harder to take this pawn
because it's defended by black's bishop
but maybe magnus is not being greedy he
doesn't care about this black pawn it's
not running away and it's fine if black
defends it
um okay this is actually magnus's idea
he drops his bishop back look at all the
pieces now eyeing up this pawn
so that these tactical points don't work
yeah we saw in one variation right that
yeah black was suffering on the eighth
row okay
um
not quite sure i like dude's last move
it just seems very very defensive you
know that he's lined up both his rooks
in the defense of that black pawn on a3
to just support a pawn push push harry
the h41 square to destabilize black's
pawns david
we have an ex something called an
exchange sacrifice on the board and it's
a it's a meanie
look at dude's face as well he shook his
head and kind of raised his eyebrows in
appreciation
it's a great move yeah and okay we have
to show this but duda is down to 10
seconds so we have to keep an eye on him
as well because this move giving up his
rook on this square most humans would
never even dream of it bishop takes rook
it looks like you've just lost material
with white but after the pawn recaptures
look at these guys they're simply going
to march forward they're going to push
and become a new queen or at least force
black to give up one of his rooks or
knights to stop them also next move no
matter what you'll take upon yourself as
white and this one will soon join its
fellows and too many pawns it would be a
pawn storm so duda doesn't take the bait
but what a classy move by magnus putting
his rook on this square cutting out this
bishop from the game as well to capture
this rook and then activate the black
rook later on okay he does take this
it's the most natural move and okay
we're headed straight for this position
but no he doesn't bring his rook across
because that would allow white's knight
to get active to a really nice
centralized square instead he shuts down
the activity of his opponent's knight i
wouldn't be panicking here for okay he
does offer a trade of knights and note
how if black gets greedy with the black
rook and takes the white bishop
after a couple of trades we will see
white's knight capture the black knight
in the central aboard so he's not
hanging his bishop he's just
counter-attacking against black knight
we do see a trade
bishop takes and something that did
worry me is this rook takes pawn maybe
you could retreat the white bishop but
why not just push report okay
the white king has one safe square in
front of it i don't think the black
brooks have time to
trap it there no there's just no time
unless he's really good at that kind of
cold cold-blooded just pure calculation
and okay young kristoff duda he puts his
rook behind one of the pawns stopping
that from advancing
but what can even just block off that
rook yep
drop his bishop back precise till the
end yeah maybe you just have to make a
move step your rook okay
okay
now you can just walk your pawns through
to the destination and he's done it
okay the rook is under attack needs to
move sideways
and as soon as that rook moves the other
pawn will step forward it's just game
over those pawns are too strong
and therefore dude just resigns about to
lose wow in the first game in the
quarter-final win for magnus carlsen
with the white pieces